another decision likely to divide a
nation
based on chapter 72 of the constitution
i announced today at this historical
moment the dissolution of the
representative council to protect the
state
had acted after 124 of parliament's 217
members held an online meeting on
wednesday their first since he suspended
the legislature eight months ago a few
hours later the president responded
unfortunately we are witnessing a coup
attempt but it is a failed one the
national duty requires today the
protection of all the people and the
homeland based on the articles of the
constitution
baku is exactly what opponents have
spent months accusing syed of staging
since last july when he sacked the prime
minister froze parliament and granted
himself new sweeping powers
he felt threatened and then i tried to
get them arrested the prosecutor general
said i won't arrest him i have no
evidence and now he's saying okay
parliament's finished but this is these
are the acts of someone who
is lashing out at uh anyone he considers
a political opposition he doesn't want a
dialogue with those that don't agree
with him
the 64 year old was a constitutional law
professor before taking up politics
in december he announced he'd appoint a
committee to rewrite the constitution
and put it to a referendum in june
meanwhile the country is experiencing
its worst recession since the 1950s
unemployment is high the war in ukraine
has driven up food prices
and months of political tension have
done little to lessen the internal
political wranglings and corruption that
syed claims forced him to suspend
parliament in the first place
but what does seem clear is that the
latest standoff is another blow to
tunisia's shaky democracy
al jazeera